[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
photo mc pensé à moi
les chaussures géraldine sa chronique
chaque semaine je vais vous faire un
petit cadeau à ses choix ses coûts
comment il va suisse il savait vous il a
des nouvelles
oui j'ai de nouvelles depuis toute
l'équipe de toute l'équipe mais surtout
j'ai un rêve sert il que je faisais part
avoué la semaine dernière vous savez
semaine dernière je me suis permis
d'imiter jean luc reichmann
oui c'est vrai bon et bien d'ailleurs
mais j'ai un rêve que je sais pas vous
mais c'est quoi y a que vous qui voyez
le réaliser c'est quoi c'est de faire
une question coquine
non et je sais que vous êtes le champion
avec jean-luc et voilà je vais pas vous
demander là aujourd'hui je vous envoie
la musique franchement aller
j'appelais encore la soul
j'adore
alors allez-y
allez sur 100 français comme your estime
que pour garder tout s'apprend princesse
il faudrait que roy monde et que caresse
bon d'accord on les bat olalalala turc
l'indiquent de la rédac vous savez je
vois tout et surtout ce soir je dénonce
tout et cette semaine cyril lundi 41 à
quelque chose avec jean michel jean
michel c'est un homme de conviction qui
n'aime pas quelqu'un il le dit il le
clame haut et fort vraiment il a des
convictions juin sauf quand cette
personne peut lui apporter quelque chose
et c'est ce qui s'est passé avec jean
pascal
ah oui l'ambiance est très forte et oui
regardez bien le monial suivre me
connaissent entre eux le jour mi au
début du magnéto et le genre me à la fin
du magnéto regardez bien ces deux salles
deux ambiances
cl s
[Musique]
je sais pas quel âge est exactement à
son âge et des bobos mais pas de
débouchés la mémoire moi les gens là tu
vois pas je me regardais c'est quoi ça
c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
j'ai fait un complément l'ambassade sur
un petit peu moins ah oui sinon après
moi j'aime bien le personnage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est au bout non parce qu'elle tient à
voir avec moi je t'aime
bon bah moi je t'aime pour toi tu le
sais des années je t'aime pour moi mais
méfie toi de lui mais il est sage et
abidal c'est quoi mais c'est très très
drôle surtout que la montre est là quoi
[Applaudissements]
d'autre chose si vous nous rejoignez
c'est lundi que la rédac je sais que
vous adorez cette séquence et tout ce
qui se passe
aulas lui voit des trucs voilà
incroyable oui il me balance tout c'est
ça oui c'est vous savez les duos en télé
ça cartonne
bien sûr il ya eu charly et lulu il ya
eu bataille et fontaine et black &
decker est gagnant cyril et sasha mais
plus cyril que s'acharne et figurez vous
qu'il ya un autre duo qui s'est formée
cyril sur votre plateau non sans pattes
au tpp
et oui c'est qui c'est bernard montiel
oui et patrice laffont non à ben oui
alors vous allez voir les gars sont en
roue libre cette année ils balancent
tout on les appelle les papys flingueurs
allez y ait un gros cul patrice tout va
bien oui moi très bien travailler voilà
ça c'est francs c'est carré voilà c'est
patrice la fois très original maintenant
mais c'est bien pas original du tout me
[Musique]
dis moi
pour une fois qu'il est bien habillé ni
série et
aujourd'hui ouais je sais qu'il est fou
de moi il veut me confier ses soirées
bennabi disque ses baskets j'aime pas du
tout s'était bien passé c'est cher
que gérer
tellement maladie c'est sur lui
classique mais la connexion navire est
inconnue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais compris qu'on va voir beaucoup
patrice laffont la semaine prochaine
d'un gène altéré bravo caissière il est
gêné oui j'ai dit ça oui bilal village
c'est un modèle d'élégance bilal est ce
que tu trouves que je suis mal habillés
aujourd'hui oui nadar et légaux est-ce
que tu as regardé ma collection
j'étais pas au courant avec l'envoyé
sept mois est battue je te fais un petit
club sans voix eh ben vas-y allez vas-y
c'est parti ces villas pour les
chroniqueurs mais y en a un petit peu
pour vous aussi pourquoi on perd on le
sait chaque semaine je diffuse un
magnéto qui s'appelle un amour de
patrons mais c'est vrai et dans lequel
on voit tout l'amour que vous portez
belle bande de cogner j'adore un autre
manière mais c'est de l'amour quand même
par exemple quand vous dites à jean mi
té dégueulasse oui c'est de l'amour
quand même et je la mer de l'est mais
voilà c'est fait raison en tout cas
syrie on peut vous reconnaître une chose
vous êtes capable de passer de je te
clash achetant biance en une fraction de
seconde
et c'est là où on voit tout votre talent
thierry alléchant mais elle échoue me
reconnaissais pas michou non mais vous
connaissez vous êtes bien vos mères
[Musique]
je voulais vous dire là c'est super ce
que vous faites vous êtes très peu
présent c'est génial pour l'émission
du coup
mais là d'amour j'adore jouer au point
de rater la dent may de l'amour mon
nikon sabrina canada c'est à partir de
là ça va rêver alors rover janvier alors
à la jambe mais on va calmer un peu les
choses surtout depuis qu'il est à côté
de kelly à la rentrée un peu plus le
contre les gens me tirait alors que là
on a vu les papys flingueurs
ceux qui lancent un peu des vannes sur
tout le monde qui charest tout le monde
mais c'est pire cyril janvier kelly
puisque ce qui ce clash entre même avec
je sais donc parfois ça donne des
situations peu bizarre franchement on a
un concept cyril après j'aime bien ce
lancement un peu france 3 ou france -
après un gars une fille retrouvé un gars
une kelly c pour
[Musique]
je sais pas les chances en blond
remarquez que ma mère
avis sur place regardez la connaissez
non
[Applaudissements]
byron moi comme tous les verbes sûr très
mal joué avec un mal de dents
[Musique]
saha
mais rien
[Musique]
et je crois moi le cherchiez johnny
clegg
oui johnny clegg j'embrasse la montée
n'est pas du tout un manque de respect
c'est de faire du jeudi se lit dans ta
maison très bien boire un thé m'a-t-on
dit je mangerais bien les fesses mais
c'est sans ses deux enfants
excusez-nous vidal a bien entendu et on
envoie sa brawn à l'offre qui est de
plus en plus jolie
oui voilà m et voilà vous n'avez pas
toutes les côtes et les chiffres merci à
l'élite ce qu'elles étaient toutes en
chine en fait c'est pensable quils et en
salopette brassac des médias comme assez
drôle olive à montchanin à quoi nos
séries j'ai une petite question
ouais vous dites plutôt le ou la wii fit
jeudi le wi-fi le wifi
oui pour lui si vous tapez 1 pour là où
il fut vous tapez 2 62 500 par sms 39 80
par téléphone nous aurons la réponse
dans un instant parce que cyril pourquoi
on dit le ou la wi fi on dit le en vrai
ouais mais parce que quand on a des
soucis de wifi qu'est ce qu'on fait nous
c'est trop long sasha c'est vrai ça va
je peux faire mon lancement tranquille
alors pourquoi parce que quand on a un
problème de wifi qu'est ce qu'on fait en
débranchant des branches aux robes roche
on n'a pas un opérateur
mais c est pas pareil quand il ya un
problème de wi2wi fille lui il arrache
il appelle du monde mais quand je dis
l'appel du monde c'est des gens très
hauts placés
rien n'est si le wifi
j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de toi sinon
comment je fais pour commencer j'ai pas
pouvoir ainsi capte pas ici ça va pas
être possible commande est correct mais
non j'ai rien je capte pas ici c'est pas
pouvoir acheter sur ce matos il captera
pas pouvoir rester sur ce plateau si je
capte pas j'aurai est-ce qu'on peut pas
voir le wifi problème le médecin de
l'avoir moi trouvons mais on va s'en
aller si vous non moi je viens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
maintenant j'ai pas pouvoir rester chaud
je m'envoie rester sur ce match on n'a
pas pu je vous dis dans mes cheveux je
vous le dis comme je le pense voilà mais
la question que tout le monde se pose du
coup est-ce que vous avez loupé je te
dis oui
voilà
la barre toi merci
[Applaudissements]